[Música]
ah
la tierra
queda verlas aquí porque a mí me
impresiona esta imagen todavía
es icónica de hecho yo creo que a mucha
gente aquí la conocerá la previsto en
millones de veces probablemente verdad
lo que no sabéis quizás la historia que
está detrás de la imagen
esta imagen fue tomada por una de las
misiones apolo allá al final de la
década de los 60 cuando orbitaba la luna
se le ha bautizado tiene un nombre como
la salida de la tierra igual que el
amanecer la tierra verdad porque es lo
que es
y es de hecho está catalogada como las
imágenes más carismáticas de la historia
y es básicamente debido a dos razones
porque transmite dos ideas fundamentales
la primera es de belleza creo que ahí
estamos todos de acuerdo la imagen es
muy bonita
y tenemos un planeta que es muy bello
muy bonito y aparte es muy fotogénico
sale muy bien en las fotos
y la segunda es de fragilidad y creo que
lo mejor también podemos coincidir
del planeta nuestro planeta aparece solo
pequeño
y frente a un fondo muy muy oscuro
es el balance el equilibrio en nuestra
tierra es bella pero también es frágil y
además hasta donde sabemos es única
y hoy más que nunca sabemos que está
seriamente amenazada
y mantener nuestro estilo de vida
tiene un precio
generalmente dado en forma de impacto en
el ambiente
es más la mayor parte de las veces creo
que no somos conscientes del impacto
real no somos conscientes de que todo lo
que hacemos que consumimos tiene una
repercusión en la naturaleza
no podemos obviarlo no podemos ignorarla
y además creo que tampoco debemos porque
allí en la naturaleza es donde
probablemente se encuentran las
respuestas a todos los grandes retos que
tenemos por delante como civilización y
como especie claro lo que tenemos que
hacer es estudiarla entenderla
comprenderla
ahora ya hablar de proyecciones el
futuro
fijaos
esto es lo que viene naciones unidas
dice que la población a nivel mundial va
a seguir creciendo actualmente somos
unos 8.000 millones de habitantes de
aquí al 2050 vamos a crecer 2 chinas
hasta la increíble cifra de 10 mil
millones de habitantes 10 mil millones
lo repito 11 y 10 ceros
hace unos meses las naciones unidas
también publicó otro informe donde habla
del impacto continuado a la naturaleza y
que a este ritmo de degradación nuestro
planeta va a dejar de ser habitable de
aquí al 2050
y esta misma semana
hoy mismo de hecho
escuchamos las conclusiones de otro
informe de naciones unidas con
perspectivas nada halagüeñas
yo os voy hablar de un sector muy
concreto alimentación
y concretamente la demanda de carne o de
proteína de origen animal vamos a decir
esto es otro informe de la fao de la
organización de naciones unidas para
alimentación la agricultura y esto es lo
que dice esto es básicamente lo que
producimos anualmente a nivel global y
aunque la gráfica parece que es poquito
esto equivale más o menos a unos 1000
millones de toneladas de carne al año
pero a mí lo que más te impacta es lo
que viene de aquí al 2050 esta demanda
se va a incrementar de media un 60%
es decir en 2050 vamos a tener que
producir más de la mitad de lo que
producimos ahora más
alguien que todas cuentas esto equivale
más o menos de aquí al 2050 a producir
tanta carne como la que nuestra
civilización ha producido en los últimos
10.000 años
esto es lo que viene
la ganadería tal y como la conocemos no
es sostenible a largo plazo
la ganadería en sí mismo consume
recursos
muchos de los cuales a veces son escasos
y el incremento de la producción no va a
cubrir la demanda
sin pagar un precio altísimo
probablemente no podemos competir nos
pagar ese precio
cuanto a los aquí presentes comen carne
una vez a la semana porque es la semana
la mayoría
esto lo que cuesta producir un filete
eres conscientes de que cuando
consumimos un filete este es consumido
el equivalente a 17 bañeras de agua
no digo que estoy teniendo 17 mañana
sábado con el filete sino que para
producir ese filete
se han invertido 17 bañeras de agua unos
3000 litros
si saca la calculadora y te pones a
hacer cuentas las cuentas no salen
y esto es el futuro
qué es lo que vamos a hacer la gran
pregunta
como vamos a reducir el impacto sin
mermar en lo más mínimo nuestra calidad
de vida
bueno yo creo que hay esperanza
lo creo si no no estaría aquí de eso
de hecho creo que esa misma esperanza es
la que me hizo convertirme lo que es hoy
en día que soy biólogo yo soy un biólogo
y además lo supe desde siempre desde que
era pequeñito y creo
siempre me ha fascinado la naturaleza
están en el campo y salía y recogía
recolectada insectos y demás los
coleccionaba luego les colocaba las
patitas y demás recuerdo que los metía
en tubitos y los metía en el congelador
al lado de los filetes congelados del
pescado
canela por abría el congelador y vería
una araña un escarabajo alucinaría un
poco
y como todos vosotros también yo me
traigo a los documentales de la tele
después de comer pero a diferencia de
vosotros yo no me quedaba dormido o por
lo menos no siempre yo quería hacer eso
realmente no un descubridor un
aventurero y hoy lo que quiero es traer
o es un pequeño viaje una pequeña
aventura un pequeño viaje de
descubrimiento y un poco de esperanza
espero hace unos años yo descubrí el
concepto de economía circular
no es nuevo ya muchos seguro que suena
pero las consecuencias son dramáticas lo
vais a ver esto es un modelo de economía
lineal desde una materia de una fuente
de recursos se obtiene un producto y
siempre se genera un desecho un residuo
que no tiene ningún valor y ese sistema
como podéis fácilmente entender no es
sostenible en cuanto que te quedas sin
fuente o sin recurso lo único que te
queda es un montón de basura
estamos ahora inmersos según en qué
ámbito en lo que podríamos llamar un
sistema de economía en bucle o en
espiral donde conceptos como el
reciclaje o la reutilización están
reforzados
es un poco mejor pero se siguen
generando residuos desechos
en un modelo de economía circular
todo
se reutiliza se recicla
se rediseña se repara se redistribuye
en definitiva
no se generan desechos o mejor dicho
cambiando la perspectiva los residuos
acaban convertidos en recursos
y esto también es futuro o debería serlo
y es por lo que yo digo que hay también
esperanza
y una vez más la naturaleza es la que
tiene la clave
fijaos en los océanos por ejemplo
tres cuartas partes del planeta están
cubiertos de agua y sin embargo llamamos
a este planeta tierra alguien dijo que
este planeta nunca tendría que haberse
llamado a sí te tenía que llamar océano
y la paradoja es que conocemos mejor la
superficie de marte que nuestros propios
océanos
pues de ahí desde hace años quiero
presentar un a un gusano o como
digo hay un gusano con sorpresa se llama
osea dax
y a mí me parece muy bonito pero
entiendo que alguno no está de acuerdo
de hecho bonita porque es una chica
es muy pequeñito apenas unos milímetros
y es un pariente lejano de la honra de
tierra
esas plumas que tiene por encima los
utiliza para respirar y ese tipo de raíz
que veis es lo que utiliza para comer
porque no tiene boca
se conoce como una docena de especies
más o menos distribuidas hasta ahora
distribuidas por diferentes océanos y
mares del mundo pero todos ellos tienen
una característica en común su dieta
servidor que se alimentan
se alimentan de huesos de ballena
fijaos cuando una ballena muere su
cuerpo se hunde se deposita en el fondo
del océano y allí no se queda sirve de
sustento para mantener comunidades muy
complejas y muy diversas de diferentes
animales y otros organismos carroñeros
cuando todo el tejido blando desaparece
el único que queda es el esqueleto
bueno pues estos gusanos han aprendido a
colonizar la superficie del hueso y poco
a poco perforar hacer pequeños agujeros
que utilizan como casa mientras que se
van consumiendo y comiéndose el hueso
literalmente
como lo hacen es un poco un misterio
todavía
pero claro aún nos estaba preguntando y
porque el hueso
qué es lo que tiene el hueso
pues es que el hueso no deja de ser una
proteína
el principal componente del hueso es de
hecho colágeno una proteína que muchos
sonarán por las
arrugas algunos les van a seguro
si no sabemos muy bien cómo lo hace pero
hace unos años pensamos bueno y si come
los huesos de ballena se comerá un hueso
de vaca
pues lo que decidimos intentar averiguar
y entonces realizamos un experimento in
situ cogimos una jaula típica de las que
se utilizan para pescar cangrejos y la
llenamos con
residuos del deshuesado después del
despiece de la industria cárnica
diferentes huesos diferentes animales y
lo metimos en el mar a unos 70 metros de
profundidad a las afueras de bergen en
noruega en el fiordo y ahí se quedó
durante dos meses ya los dos meses
fuimos a observar qué es lo que había
con una cámara subacuática
y lo que vimos es que aquello estaba en
ebullición estaba lleno de vida gusanos
por todas partes una masa de gusanos que
se movía entre medio de los huesos la
superficie los huesos cubiertos también
de otro tipo de gusanos diferentes y
cuando nos subimos a la superficie puf
también teníamos addax todo lleno ahora
no me digáis que son no son bonitos
claro estos bichos nunca han visto un
hueso de vaca
había novedad dijimos aquí hay potencial
realmente
queríamos intentar estudiar un poco más
porque como
la idea se basa en dos premisas la
primera es lo hemos visto ya el
crecimiento de la población viene
acompañado un incremento de la demanda
de proteína de origen animal
es necesariamente vendrá acompañada de
un incremento en la generación de vamos
a decir recursos óseos
y la segunda es muy clara si somos
capaces de aprender como la naturaleza
recicla el hueso a sus componentes más
elementales quizá seamos capaces de
establecer un sistema equivalente donde
podemos transformar un residuo en un
producto de mayor calidad y valor
economía circular lo hemos dicho
claro esta idea siempre es mucho más
fácil de decir que de hacer lo primero
que lleva a cierta dificultad es
convencer al organismo financiación
financiador que te tiene que dar el
dinero tiene que pagar el proyecto
verdad y eso no siempre es fácil pero es
que el proyecto en sí mismo pues no está
exento de dificultades y de retos
ya mismo recoger las muestras obtenerlas
es difícil extraer las analizarlas
procesar las muchísimo trabajo y ni
siquiera es un trabajo de una persona
esto requiere colaboración con la
oración internacional
nosotros hemos sido capaces de montar
una especie de consorcio con gente muy
competente de diferentes diferentes
ámbitos desde la biología marina
microbiología biología molecular
en diferentes países e noruega
aquí en españa en alemania en rumanía y
gracias a ese proyecto piloto
a ese consorcio ya un plan muy detallado
hemos logrado financiación de la unión
europea para intentar descubrir y
producir los secretos que utiliza la
naturaleza para reciclar unos de
materiales más recalcitrantes que
existen el hueso
es un ejemplo
es un pequeño viaje como os decía sólo
uno de los probablemente millones que
están ahí fuera
muchos de los cuales están todavía por
descubrir verdad es parte de esa belleza
de la que hablábamos del planeta y
también de la fragilidad
solo una economía circular puede
asegurarnos un futuro sostenible
y el conocimiento científico a la
investigación nos pueden dar las
herramientas para alcanzar ese modelo
así que os invito
a tener un poco de esperanza a pensar
que si es posible
a que seamos conscientes del impacto que
causamos pero también a confiar en los
avances tecnológicos que vendrán
a soñar a pensar que un mundo más limpio
sin residuos es posible
para que podamos seguir disfrutando de
imágenes como esta
gracias
[Aplausos]